He’s tall, thin, faceless, and wears a dark
suit.
Once he’s in your life—you’re doomed.
If you try to learn more about him or even
think about him, it only makes it easier for
him to find you.
He’s the notorious Internet monster—Slender
Man.
This 21st-century monster gained popularity
as more and more content was created and shared
about him, enough so that he jumped the digital
border and began to infiltrate other media.
Video games, comic books, and movies show
him stalking humans.
People also dress up like him and hunt for
him in the woods.
Then...there’s the tragic attempted murder
of a 12-year-old girl in 2014 that made him
a household name.
Unlike so many other monsters we know exactly
when this one was created and by whom, a rarity
made possible by the Internet.
His obscurity is what makes him scary, but
the real impact of this monster is how he
changed folklore forever.
[Monstrum intro.]
On June 8, 2009 the online forum Something
Awful posted a photoshop challenge: “turn
ordinary photographs into creepy-looking images
through digital manipulation.”
User Victor Surge, whose real name is Eric
Knudsen, responded on June 10
with two black and white photographs.
The first photograph shows a group of teenagers
walking towards the camera.
Behind them, you can barely make out a tall,
blurry figure lurking in the background.
The teens seem unaware of his presence.
The second photograph depicts a more clear
image of Slender Man.
It shows children happily playing in a playground,
but in the background under a tree, a shadowy
fig-yur looms.
In this photo, it appears that Slender Man
also has tentacles, almost overnight, Slender
Man became an internet sensation.
As his mythos evolved, some common traits
emerged.
Slender Man is described as noticeably taller
than the average human with an oddly proportioned
body.
He’s very thin with long arms and legs,
and in some accounts, he can sprout tentacles
from his back.
He wears a suit and has no facial features
or hair and his skin is unnaturally pale.
Anyone who sees Slender Man is then stalked
by him.
So it becomes a sort of creepy loop; the more
he is seen, the more commonly he appears.
So the fact that I’m making this video means
I’m already doomed.
What made Victor Surge’s post stand out
more than other submissions was that it was
the first to create a narrative that accompanied
the images.
He posted the photos with the following text:
“One of two recovered photographs from the
Stirling City Library blaze Notable for being
taken the day which fourteen children vanished
and for what is referred to as ‘The Slender
Man.’
Deformities cited as film defects by officials.
Fire at library occurred one week later.
Actual photograph confiscated as evidence.
1986, photographer: Mary Thomas, missing since
June 13th, 1986.”
Slenderman was born from those words.
The context crafted the myth.
Something Awful users instantly latched on
to the mysterious monster’s story.
The Slender Man post sparked enthusiastic
comments, with many noting how it would make
for a great tv show or a book.
Others quickly jumped on to the Slender Man
bandwagon by posting their own accounts of
the creature.
Within days, the thread became almost exclusively
made up of “real” Slender Man legends.
One notable post from a user with the screen
name ce gars, mentions his own investigation
into a film project that caused his friend
to become increasingly disturbed.
A few days later, the film project in question
was uploaded to YouTube, under the title Marble
Hornets.
It features a story, inspired by Slender Man,
about a boogeyman figure capable of distorting
audio and video recordings causing the film’s
creator to be driven insane.
It turned out that ce gars was Troy Wagner,
who crafted the series with his friends.
Marble Hornets became a huge part of the monster’s
mythos and was incredibly successful, totaling
more than 90 found-footage episodes.
It even helped inspire two Slender Man video
games.
Slender Man made his Creepypasta debut on
January 14, 2010.
Creepypasta developed as a place to collect
spooky stories.
Users would“copy” and “paste” “creepy”
texts from other web sites such as 4chan.
Some people argue that Creepypasta and others
such as the /nosleep subreddit obscure the
truth.
They are veiled behind a faux authenticity—fictional
stories, often accompanied by seemingly authentic
images—that are treated as real.
But as a scholar of the Gothic, I can tell
you that treating mythical stories as actual
accounts is nothing new at all.
Some original Gothic novels were published
and falsely advertised as “translations”
of “newly discovered” manuscripts by real
authors, or alongside claims that they were
true accounts from some anonymous writer.
But, in reality they were completely fabricated.
More recently, found footage horror films
[Blair Witch, etc.] are another example of
how the lines of fiction and truth are intentionally
blurred.
Victor Surge admits Slender Man was made up.
An idea he crafted from all the things that
scare him with a name he says he “thought
up on the fly”
He does admit he used the Tall Man from the
Phantasm films as the source material for
the first Slender Man images.
But by keeping the details vague, he allowed
others to fill in the gaps of his creation
with their own fears.
Slender Man shares similarities to a lot of
other pre-existing characters.
He’s been compared to the Pied Piper, Buffy
the Vampire Slayer’s the Gentlemen, The
Silence from Dr. Who, the Men in Black, and
Jack Skellington.
Tales about him contain some elements of the
Blair Witch Project and H.P.
Lovecraft stories.
There’s even a pre-existing Japanese yokai
that appears human but has no facial features,
just like Slender Man.
You may have heard that Slender Man sightings
have been happening for hundreds of years,
that he appears in old texts and art, from
Germanic mythology to Canadian folklore, Norse
mythology, and Egyptian hieroglyphics.
It’s enticing to think that we can discover
a monster that’s been secretly haunting
us for years.
That’s a cool story.
But none of that is true.
He didn’t exist before 2009.
Take this image for example.
Some people claim this is an image of Slender
Man dating back to the 16th century, but in
reality it’s a photoshopped image based
on existing prints from that time period.
The original comes from a series of danse macabre images
meant to show that death is universal.
This one?
Another photoshop of an image taken from the
same artist.
Similar to other monsters, such as Windigo
and Tokoloshe, Slender Man has been used as
a scapegoat for deviant behavior.
In 2014, two girls attempted to murder their
friend because they allegedly thought it would
attract the attention of Slender Man.
Such a dramatic and violent crime drew the
attention of the media, and the once notorious
Internet monster became a familiar story offline
as well, causing moral panic and fear.
Slender Man’s faceless features allow us
to transcribe pretty much any of our fears
onto him.
He’s uncanny.
His human silhouette and common clothing makes
him familiar.
But something is off.
His dark suit is unsettling.
There could be a couple of reasons why:
It shows him polished and put together, and
intentional in what he does.
He is self aware, patiently waiting and watching
his victims.
There’s also the association of black suits
with death, something we see commonly at funerals.
And then there’s the idea that the suit
symbolizes power and authority.
It’s anonymous and timeless.
The idea that Slender Man specifically targets
children feeds into our fear that there are
evil strangers ready to kidnap our kids.
Slender Man’s the new version of “don’t
take candy from a stranger,” a lesson that
keeps kids safe by instilling a healthy wariness
for adults they don’t know.
Slender Man is always watching you, even if
you don’t know it.
This parallels our more legitimate fears of
being constantly watched by cameras and other
technologies that monitor our day to day actions.
Heck, even the Internet where Slender Man
was first created constantly logs so much
of what we do.
Slender Man takes the fear of something that
seems abstract, like a story on the Internet,
to something more concrete like a man outside
your window at night.
Slender Man could have been nothing more than
a scary, made up story.
But when people misread it, treat it as real,
the lines between what is authentic and what
is false blur to dangerous levels.
Technology allows anyone to make fake things
appear real.
Photoshopped images, computer edited video
footage, and falsified documents can spread
quickly and are seen as legitimate.
And anyone can contribute.
Slender Man represents an important shift
in folklore where myths are crafted at a blistering
pace across social, cultural, and physical
boundaries.
It’s a kind of digital Gothic where the
haunted house becomes the haunted everything.
Slender Man and other digital folklore succeeds
because of the Internet.
These myths spread like wildfire through social
media.
The time stamps of online folklore allow us
to examine real-time discussions, responses,
and reactions to mythology as it’s created.
It gives us an exact account of how the story
developed in real time—something that doesn’t
didn’t exist in traditional folklore studies
before.
I think this is part of what makes Slender
Man so popular, what gives him life—he can
be made by anyone for anyone.
Slender Man unintentionally revolutionized
how horror stories are told.
He opened up the doors for anyone with an
internet connection to help create a legend.